[Musique]
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité celle 2022 le
but est de dépenses de la branche
autonomie a été fixé à 34 2 milliards
d'euros c'est l'assemblée sommes
importantes mais qui est en décalage
complet au regard des besoins de cette
nouvelle manche je rappelle la gestion
des personnes âgées et des personnes
handicapées qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui nous avons au fur et à
mesure des pelles fss des mesures
complémentaires qui viennent régler des
difficultés d urgence n'est toujours
sans réelle vision globale des exemples
et bien à travers cette manque de vision
nous avons souhaité nous ici au sénat
voté la mise en place d'un comité
stratégique de coordination de leurs
soldes des financeurs de façon à ce
qu'on puisse forcer le gouvernement à se
poser pour écrire cette fameuse loi sur
l'autonomie deuxième exemple le ségur de
la santé des mesures financières
d'accompagnement pour les personnes
proches des personnes handicapées
personnages et pour lequel il revenait à
son 283 euros était attendue depuis
longtemps enfin le gouvernement
proposait mesure pour rectifier le tir
mais de nouveau nous ne savons même pas
si l'ensemble des personnels concernés
et bien sont touchés par cette nouvelle
mesure donc la volonté était de mettre
en place un comité de suivi justement
des mesures du secteur de la santé en
matière de handicap quelques mesures
quelques millions d'euros mais qui sont
en décalage complet par rapport aux
besoins on est réellement d'une petite
de saupoudrage et pour terminer nous
avons également la mise en place d'un
nouveau service de gestion du domicile
mais de nouveau une partie des acteurs
du service à domicile ne sont pas
concernés par cette réforme et nous nous
pourrons nous en sortir que lorsque nous
aurons réellement cette capacité
d'écrire et de faire voter au parlement
une véritable loi sur l'autonomie
[Musique]